[Music]
now might be a really good time for you
to get angry
that's my secret captain
i'm always angry
hold on
the late 2000's may have heralded the
arrival of a new breed of superhero
movies with the likes of iron man and
the dark knight but who could have
predicted their utter pop culture
domination of the last 10 years well
maybe kevin feige naturally you can't
talk about these momentous leaps from
panel to screen without mention of the
marvel studios mastermind who cobbled
together iconic heroes into the avengers
i mean even that seemed like a miracle
of blockbuster needle threading at the
time but it nearly pales in comparison
to the biggest movie ever avengers
endgame
avengers
assemble
next to marvel was dc comics and their
dc extended universe which started with
man of steel and still continues till
this day but the x-men franchise finally
sputtered to its end but not before
reaching top forms with days of future
past and the oscar-nominated logan
if you allow yourself to feel it
embrace it
that will make you more powerful than
you ever imagined
whatever the style or budget it is time
to face forward into the best superhero
movies of the 2010s
[Music]
number 10 marvel's the avengers
when thor's evil brother loki gains
access to the unlimited power of the
energy cube called the tesseract nick
fury initiates a superhero recruitment
effort to defeat the unprecedented
threat to earth joining fury's dream
team are iron man captain america the
hulk thor black widow and hawkeye
starring robert downey jr chris evans
scarlett johansson and directed by joss
whedon critics say thanks to a script
that emphasizes its hero's humanity and
a wealth of superpowered set pieces the
avengers lives up to its hype and raises
the bar for marvel at the movies
stark
get a lot of space sniffing your tail
just trying to
keep them off the streets well they
can't bank with a dam
find a tight corner i will roger that
[Applause]
[Music]
nice call
what else you got
number nine guardians of the galaxy
brash face adventurer peter quill finds
himself the quarry of relentless bounty
hunters after he seals an orb coveted by
ronin a powerful villain to evade ronin
quill is forced into an uneasy truce
with four disparate misfits rocket
raccoon groot gamora and drax the
destroyer but when he discovers that the
orb's true power and the cosmic threat
it poses quill must rally his ragtag
group to save the universe starring
chris pratt zoe saldana vin diesel
bradley cooper dave bautista and
directed by james gunn critics say
guardians of the galaxy is just as
irreverent as fans of the frequently
zany marvel comic would expect as well
as funny thrilling full of heart and
packed with visual splendor
while i'm trapped
[Music]
these things aren't meant to go out
there
you are disappointed sister
out of all our siblings
i hated you at least
if ronan gets this stone he'll kill us
all
not all
you will already be dead
number eight spider-man homecoming
thrilled by his experience with the
avengers young peter parker returns home
to live with his aunt may under the
watchful eye of mentor tony stark parker
starts to embrace his newfound identity
as spider-man he also tries to return to
his normal daily routine distracted by
thoughts of proving himself to be more
than just a friendly neighborhood
superhero peter mussoon put his powers
to the test when the evil vulture
emerges to threaten everything that he
holds dear starring tom holland michael
keaton robert downey jr and directed by
john watts critics say spider-man
homecoming does whatever a second reboot
can delivering a colorful fun adventure
that fits snugly in a sprawling mcu
without getting bogged down in franchise
building
[Music]
gave you a choice
you chose rome oh what the hell
the crappy costume
[Music]
i wasn't sure about this thing at first
but
[Music]
gross
[Music]
why did he send you here yes you'll
never know
nice shot
number seven incredibles 2.
telecommunications guru winston dever
enlists elastigirl to fight crime and
make the public fall in love with
superheroes once again that leaves mr
incredible with one of his greatest
challenges ever staying home and taking
care of three rambunctious children as
violet dash and jack jack offer him a
new set of headaches a cyber criminal
named screenslaver launches his
dastardly plan hypnotizing the world
through computer screens starring craig
t nelson holly hunter sarah vowell and
directed by brad bird critics say
incredibles 2 reunites pixar's family
crime fighting team for a long awaited
follow-up that may not quite live up to
the original but comes close enough to
earn its name
[Music]
so
[Music]
ah
[Music]
number six thor ragnarok
imprisoned on the other side of the
universe the mighty thor finds himself
in a deadly gladiatorial contest that
pits him against the hulk his former
ally and fellow avenger thor's quest for
survival leads him in a race against
time to prevent the all-powerful hela
from destroying his homeworld and the
asgardian civilization starring chris
hemsworth tom hiddleston cate blanchett
and directed by taika watiti critics say
exciting funny and above all fun thor
ragnarok is a colorful cosmic adventure
that sets a new standard for its
franchise and the rest of the marvel
cinematic universe
we're fulfilling the prophecy i hate
this prophecy so do i but we have no
choice
certain destroys asgard he destroys
hella so that our people may live
but we need to let him finish the job
otherwise
i'll stop you [ __ ]
[Music]
oh stop just for once in your life don't
smash
big monster
let's go
number five wonder woman
before she was wonder woman she was
diana princess of the amazons trained to
be an unconquerable warrior raised on a
sheltered island paradise diana meets an
american pilot who tells her about the
massive conflict that's raging in the
outside world convinced that she can
stop the threat diana leaves her home
for the first time fighting alongside
men in a war to end all wars she finally
discovers her full powers and true
destiny starring gal gadot chris pine
connie nielsen and directed by patty
jenkins critics say thrilling earnest
and buoyed by gal gadot's charismatic
performance wonder woman succeeds in
spectacular fashion
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
number four logan
in the near future a weary logan cares
for an ailing professor x at a remote
outpost on the mexican border his plan
to hide from the outside world gets
upended when he meets a young mutant who
is very much like him logan must now
protect the girl and battle the dark
forces that want to capture her starring
hugh jackman patrick stewart daphne
keane and directed by james mangold
critics say hugh jackman makes the most
of his final outing as wolverine with a
gritty nuanced performance in a violent
but surprisingly thoughtful superhero
action film that defies genre
conventions hey mr monson
you understand you're trespassing right
now right i have an easement with the
previous owner of your property
previous being the operative word
who's this
this is the guy telling you to get back
in your nice truck go play okie dick
head somewhere else
hey carl
it looks like mr monson hires some
muscle
looks that way
he's a friend of mine
a friend with a big mouth
i hear that a lot
and you probably hear this too
more than i'd like
and you know the drill
i'm gonna count three
and you're gonna start walking away
right to this one one i have a lawyer
now two
three
right boss
you know the drill
get the hell out of here
number three avengers end game
a drift in space with no food or water
tony stark sends a message to pepper
potts as his oxygen supply starts to
dwindle meanwhile the remaining avengers
must figure out a way to bring back
their vanquish allies for an epic
showdown with thanos the evil demigod
who decimated the planet and the
universe starring robert downey jr chris
evans scarlett johansson and directed by
anthony and joe russo critics say
exciting entertaining and emotionally
impactful avengers end game does
whatever it takes to deliver a
satisfying finale to marvel's epic
infinity saga
five years ago we lost
all of us
we lost friends
we lost family
we lost a part of ourselves
today we have a chance to take it all
back
[Music]
you know your teams you know your
missions
get the stones get them back
one round trip each no mistakes
no do-overs
most of us are going somewhere we know
that doesn't mean we should know what to
expect
be careful
look out for each other
this is the fight of our lives
and we're gonna win
whatever it takes
good luck
he's pretty good at that right
number two black panther
after the death of his father t'challa
returns home to the african nation of
wakanda to take his rightful place as
king when a powerful enemy suddenly
reappears t'challa's medal as king and
his black panther gets tested when he's
drawn into a conflict that puts the fate
of wakanda and the entire world at risk
faced with the treachery and danger the
young king must rally his allies and
release the full power of black panther
to defeat his foes and secure the safety
of his people starring chadwick boseman
michael b jordan lupita nyong'o and
directed by ryan coogler critics say
black panther elevates superhero cinema
to thrilling new heights while telling
one of mcu's most absorbing stories and
introducing some of its most fully
realized characters
[Music]
[Music]
this is it for you cousin
[Music]
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
shazam
we all have a superhero inside of us it
just takes a bit of magic to bring it
out in 14 year old billy batson's case
all he needs to do is shout out one word
to transform into the adult superhero
shazam still a kid at heart shazam
revels in the new version of himself by
doing what any other teen would do have
fun while testing out his newfound
powers but he'll need to master them
quickly before the evil doctor thidea
savannah can get his hands on shazam's
magical abilities starring zachary levi
mark strong astroangel and directed by
david f sandberg critics say an
effortlessly entertaining blend of humor
and heart shazam is a superhero movie
that never forgets the genre's real
power joyous wish fulfillment
say my name
[Music]
really
no not my name no say the name that i
say to turn into this guy
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
guys
what's happening
[Music]
i can fly
x-men days of future past
convinced that mutants pose a threat to
humanity dr bolivar trask develops the
sentinels enormous robotic weapons that
can detect a mutant gene and zero in on
that person in the 21st century the
sentinels have evolved into highly
efficient killing machines with mutants
now facing extinction wolverine
volunteers to go back in time and rally
the x-men of the past to help change a
pivotal moment in history and thereby
save their future starring hugh jackman
james mcavoy jennifer lawrence and
directed by brian singer critics say
x-men days of future past combines the
best elements of the series to produce a
satisfyingly fast-paced outing that
ranks among the franchise's finest
installments
i'm going to keep you safe i'm going to
keep you out of their hands
eric
eric
what are you doing
securing our future
forgive me mystique
as long as you're out there we'll never
be safe
eric use your power charles stop him
he can't
and before we get to number one here is
another honorable mention
the dark knight rises
it has been eight years since batman in
collusion with commissioner gordon
vanished into the night assuming
responsibility for the death of harvey
dent batman sacrificed everything for
what he and gordon hoped would be the
greater good however the arrival of a
cunning cat burglar and a merciless
terrorist named bane forced batman out
of exile and into a battle he may not be
able to win starring christian bale and
hathaway tom hardy and directed by
christopher nolan critics say the dark
knight rises is an ambitious thoughtful
and potent action film that concludes
christopher nolan's franchise in
spectacular fashion
i'm here to fulfill razakul's destiny
ah you fight like a younger man there's
nothing held back
it's admirable
but mistaken
oh
you think darkness is your ally
you merely adopted the dark
i was born in it
molded by it
i didn't see the light until i was
already a man but then it was nothing to
me but brighton
the shadows betray you
because they belong to me
and finally number one spider-man into
the spider-verse
bitten by a radioactive spider in the
subway brooklyn teenager miles morales
suddenly develops mysterious powers that
transform him into the one and only
spider-man when he meets peter parker he
soon realizes that there are many others
who share his special high-flying
talents miles must now use his newfound
skills to battle the evil kingpin
hulking madman who can open portals to
other universes and pull different
versions of spider-man into our world
starring shameek moore jake johnson
hayley seinfeld and directed by bob
persichetti peter ramsey and rodney
rothman critics say spider-man into the
spider-verse matches bold storytelling
but striking animation for a purely
enjoyable adventure with heart humor and
plenty of superhero action your turn
yeah yeah
right
you're not going anywhere
i'll hold them off you shut this down
peter that wasn't the deal push the
green button do not wait for me
what are you doing peter you gotta go
home this guy can kill you i can't let
spiderman die neither can i
it's okay
yeah it is okay
you gotta go home man
[Music]
how do i know i'm not gonna mess it up
again
you won't
i
hate to leave the faith
[Music]
not bad kid
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love until
next time i'm your host naz perez and
we'll see you back here for more top 10s
on the rotten tomatoes countdown
you